اذا مشاهدينا الكرام ونحن على ابواب
انتهاء اليوم الثاني من الهدنه الرابعه
بين الطرفين وبدايه يوم جديد من
الاشتباكات خلال الساعات القليله القادمه
اليوم الثاني عشر من هذه الاشتباكات كان
يتمركز بطبيعه الحال في العاصمه الخرطوم
مع اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بخرق هذه
الهدنه قوات الدعم السريع قالت بان الدعم
والدعم السريع قالت بان الجيش هاجم عده
محاور اليوم متمركزا درجه اساسيه الطيران
الحربي الذي قصف مواقع في خرطوم بحري
المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه من الخرطوم وايضا بطبيعه الحال ام
درمان المنطقه الجنوبيه من ام درمان
تحديدا كانت مسرح عمليات طبعا نتحدث عن
الخرطوم الكبرى العاصمه التي تتكون من
ثلاث مدن رئيسيه الخرطوم بحري المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه والخرطوم المنطقه
الجنوبيه وام درمان المدينه الغربيه
للبلاد العمليات العسكريه ايضا
ركزت بالدرجه اساسيه داخل مدينه الخرطوم
ان كنا نتحدث عن هذا الجزء من العاصمه
السودانيه فنحن نتحدث بدرجه اساسيه عن هذا
الجزء تحديدا ملتقى النيلين في العاصمه
السوداني وهذه الصوره اقرب للمربع الامني
المهم الذي تدور فيه العمليات العسكريه
اليوم وتدور فيه ايضا التهابات المتبادله
بين الطرفين قوات الدعم السريع تتمركز
بشكل اساسي عند مطار الخرطوم في الجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه من مطار الخرطوم الذي
نشاهده على الشاشه والذي توقفت فيه الحركه
حركه ملاحه الجويه في الساعات الاولى من
هذه المعارك قبل 12 يوما قوات الدعم
السريع تتهم الجيش بانه نفذ ضربات على
نقاط تمركزها وخرق الهدنه اليوم في
المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من مطار الخرطوم
الدولي كما نشاهد على الشاشه بينما تقول
قوات الجيش بان قوات الدعم السريع هاجمت
مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه حيث
تتمركز القوات السودانيه ونفذت ضربات في
للسيطره على مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه حيث يتمركز الجيش هذا
الامر ايضا انعكس وانسحب على المنطقه
القريبه جدا في هذا المربع عندما نتحدث عن
القصر الجمهوري حيث تتمركز ايضا هناك قوات
تابعه للدعم السريع منذ الساعات الاولى
لهذا القتال الدائر منذ اثني عشر يوما
قالت قوات الدعم السريع بان قوات الجيش
حاولت اليوم شن هجمات بالطائرات على مناطق
تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في القصر
الجمهوري لتكون هذه الدائره او هذا المربع
الذي لا يتجاوز مساحته بضعه كيلو مترات
اقل من عشره كيلو مترات مربعه هي المنطقه
الاكثر اشتعالا في الخرطوم حتى هذه اللحظه
صوره اوسع عن المناطق التي سنتحدث بطبيعه
الحال عن المستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه ولكن
هناك امدادات عسكريه تاتي للجيش من
المناطق الشماليه
اتجاه العاصمه الخرطوم بحسب ما تفيد
التقارير في المقابل تاتي امدادات عسكريه
في قوات الدعم السريع قادمه من المناطق
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه وتحديدا مناطق
دارفور ومناطق جنوبيه وجنوبي غرب البلاد
حيث تتمركز قوات الدعم السريع لتكون هذه
المناطق هي مناطق ايضا عملياتيه لقوات
الدعم او الامدادات التي تزحف باتجاه
العاصمه سواء للجيش من الجهه الشماليه نحو
العاصمه او من المنطقه الغربيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه نحو العاصمه بقي نشير بشكل سريع
الى الوضع الصحي المتدهور حيث حذرت منظمه
الصحه العالميه اليوم من انهيار القطاع
الصحي قامت الاطباء السودانيه تقول ان 72%
من مستشفيات السودان التي تظهر في هذه
الخارطه 72% من هذه المستشفيات خرج عن
الخدمه بينما تقول منظمه الصحه العالميه
ناس 16% فقط من المرافق الصحيه او الطبيه
في السودان بشكل عام
تعمل فقط وهذه الخريطه التي تظهر
المستشفيات الرئيسيه في السودان وهذه
خريطه اقرب تظهر المستشفيات الرئيسيه في
العاصمه السودانيه مع التحذيرات من انهيار
الوضع الصحي والمنظومه الصحيه والطبيه
بشكل كامل في السودان مع تعرض عدد كبير من
هذه المستشفيات
للقصف واغلاق عدد كبير من هذه المستشفيات